this is hairdresser owner sorry n.com
when in this video I want to demonstrate
how to check cranial nerve 5 which is
the trigeminal nerve so what does the
trigeminal nerve do well it's
responsible for a couple things number
one is responsible for sensation in our
face and motor function it allows us to
bite down into food so first we're going
to test sensation and to do this you're
going to need a cotton ball and
something with a sharp edge an easy way
to get something with a sharp edge is to
take a cotton swab cut it in half and
this will achieve that sharp edge for
you now whenever we're testing for
sensation we're testing three areas of
the face where the trigeminal nerve
branches off and these include
ophthalmic maxillary and mandibular
regions so first what we're gonna do is
we're gonna have the patient close their
eyes and we're going to take our cotton
ball and we're going to test bilaterally
in those areas you just seen and
whenever the patient feels that tell
them to say yes and what you're looking
for is equal feeling what would be
abnormal is if they don't feel it the
same on each side or they have a
decreased response to it so tell me yes
when you feel this sensation yes yes yes
yes and because he has a beard we're
gonna go in this area right here we're
not going to go over the hair yes okay
now we're going to take our sharp object
and we're going to repeat the same way
yes yes
yes
yeah okay and lastly what we're going to
do is we're going to test the patient's
ability to differentiate between a soft
touch and a sharp touch so tell me if
you feel it sharp just say sharp or soft
okay
soft
sir
soft
sure okay now what we're going to do is
test the corneal reflex and to do this
you'll want to have the patient remove
their contacts if they wear them because
it can throw off the test you're going
to take another cotton ball and you're
sort of just going to twist it at the
end like this and what we're going to do
is have the patient's stare off and
you're going to take this part of the
cotton ball in at the side of the eye
and touch the cornea and what you're
looking for is for that eye to blink and
simultaneously that other ID to blink as
well and if that didn't happen that
would be an abnormal response okay so
we're going to go in at the side and
touch the cornea you should blink now
we're going to test motor function and
what I want you to do is I want you to
bite down for me okay and what you want
to do is take your hands and you're
gonna feel the masseter muscle in the
temporal muscle and you should feel a
nice ball of muscle that is equal on
both sides and the temporal muscle and I
feel that and now normal finding would
be if it was unequal on each side or
very small next what you want to do is
you want to see how well the patient can
move their jaw against resistance so I'm
gonna have you try to open up your jaw
against my hand that was very strong
abnormal finding would be they couldn't
do that at all and then try to move from
side to side okay okay so that is how
you test cranial nerve five now be sure
to check out my other videos on how you
test the other cranial nerves thank you
so much for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos